at the start of 2016 in a small town
called veles in macedonia an 18 year old
high school student discovered that he
could make more money than his parents
by building fake news sites to protect
his identity will call him Boris and
here's how he did it
he wrote tons of false articles about
the US election
most of them salacious the articles were
shared on Facebook garnering tons of
traffic so much so that Boris is most
popular website earned him sixteen
thousand dollars over the course of a
few months that's way higher than the
average monthly salary in Macedonia
which is three hundred and seventy one
dollars so Boris dropped out of high
school and he was not alone in the final
weeks of the election there were more
than a hundred political websites
registered to Bellis the most popular
stories were pro-trump but that's not
because boris and his fake news
publishers liked the candidate they just
liked the money Trump supporters just
happened to be more likely to share fake
news researchers tracked 30 million
shares of pro Trump stories on Facebook
in the months before the election but
why were companies advertising on fake
news sites they weren't directly those
ads were placed by services like Google
Adsense or AppNexus
which act as intermediaries between
advertisers and small-time publishers
like Boris they negotiate how much ads
cost and manage payments from
advertisers to publishers those ads
follow people wherever they go online
remember when you recently searched for
that one Z well
that search was tracked and matched with
advertisers selling that product so
everywhere you go on the web a 1zn
follows
advertisers and these services create
black lists of sites they won't
advertise against but it's hard to keep
up so sometimes they pop up on fake news
sites that haven't been discovered yet
while boris and his friends were making
money fake knees became one of the major
scandals of the 2016 elections many
wondered if sites like Boris's even
helped Trump win a joint study by NYU
and Stanford University found that it
may not have tipped the election as much
as one would think it found that one
fake news story would need to be as
persuasive as 30
six TV commercials to swing a voter fill
the backlash force tech giants like
Google and Facebook to do something
Facebook is now partnering with
fact-checking organizations like Snopes
and PolitiFact's to flag articles that
present deliberately misleading content
Google now cuts off Adsense revenue to
sites with spoof domains like New York
Times politics.com but that's still
flagging fake news after it's been
published and shared so tech companies
like mote propose combining algorithms
with human insight to catch fake news
before it spreads
[Music]